la conmoción continua en chile tras las
dolorosas imágenes que vimos el fin de
semana en la que se quemaban las
pertenencias de migrantes en el marco de
una marcha anti inmigración esto ocurría
en iquique una ciudad que se encuentra a
1800 kilómetros al norte de santiago y
que es utilizada por muchos migrantes en
su mayoría venezolanos como un lugar de
tránsito llegan a ella después de haber
atravesado el desierto más seco del
mundo y buscan la forma de llegar a
santiago otras ciudades del país donde
cuentan con familia y apoyo la fiscalía
de esta región la región de tarapacá
anunció que inició una investigación
para revisar estos vídeos y determinar
quién arrojó las pertenencias al fuego
entre las que se encontraban carros y
pañales de bebé y establecer si hubo o
no delitos como una inadmisible
humillación un ataque a los más
vulnerables ha calificado el hecho el
relator de naciones unidas en temas de
emigración felipe gonzález y el lamentó
el tono tecnófobo que se ha dado en
chile que equipa la migración con
delincuencia y que alimenta esta
barbarie son varias las organizaciones
en el país que piden al gobierno un
nuevo enfoque basado en los derechos
humanos para temas migratorios mientras
que el gobierno de chile anuncia que va
a retomar su política
y colectiva de estos migrantes en vuelos
especialmente programados para ello una
política que fue detenida tras que el
tribunal supremo se manifestara contra
ella en varias instancias afirmando que
violaba los derechos básicos de este
colectivo